pour 304 services mutualisés dédiés à la
création innovation l'information sur le
campus paris saclay est notamment liée
au croisement des communautés chercheurs
entrepreneurs étudiants industriels et
habitants
après l'inauguration à deux semaines on
a une remise des prix la semaine
dernière autour du concours mobilité
2 le ps s'il y avait donc les lauréats
des six équipes lauréates du concours
oui on a très heureux d'accueillir un
autre type d'événement qui est lié par
l'association à poils qui travaille sur
les jeux vidéo est donc là ils ont
rassemblé tous leur rétro gaming plaisir
des jeux vidéo des années 90 qui ont re
découvert puisque même n'était pas lié à
l'époque et je veux qu'ils se retrouvent
rémy 6 pour 1 pour s'affronter sur ces
plateformes
de cession à poils à 9 ans et les sur le
campus d'orsay à paris sud claire monod
très content qu'ils puissent venir ici
en tant qu'usagers du campus est donc
directement les usagers du lieu
l'intéressé dans leur événement cette
notion de retrogaming c'est à dire de
faire des vidéos
pas pour les versions à gêner notre
qualité actuelle mais vraiment de
reprendre les anciennes consoles donc là
en l'occurrence c'est le première
playstation et les messes pour nintendo
donc des pâtes on compte vingt ans et
qui se sont plus âgés que les personnes
qui sont qui joue dessus et doit ce
plaisir de jouer ce que de se retrouver
puis d'avoir des tournois ou d mon
ludique pour les uns pour les novices on
a beaucoup aimé cette notion-là doit de
faire quelque chose de manière simple et
de croiser à croiser les publics